[Musique trop stylée du Golden Moustache]
Vous avez aimé Turbo Chef...
je serais plutôt parti sur une ratatouille
provençale
et je pensais rajouter quelques saveurs
NON! On garde les yeux sur la route !
AAAAAAAH !
3, 2, 1, levez les mains ! Levez les mains !...
Ah ben non ! Ben non ! Ben non !
Vous avez aimé On n'demande qu'à en rire en terre inconnue...
Ha ha ... et puis alors c'est quoi le nouveau délire là
avec les "clopes électroniques" ?
Bientôt on va pouvoir télécharger son cancer sur Internet ! Ha ha ha !
Alors imagine t'es là et...
Aïe
[BAM]
[Zoulous dubitatifs]
Vous aller adorer...
N'oubliez pas d'épouser le juste INTER Fort
de la Fortune faible pour un Champion Factor
et ses Prince en Or LANTA
BONJOUR !
et bienvenus dans ce nouveau NPEJIFFCFPOL
Nous sommes aujourd'hui encore avec Romuald
Pour sa 151ème tentative.
Romuald, on est bientôt prêt, ça va commencer,
est-ce que vous êtes confiant ?
Euh....
Ouais, ça va...
Eh ben parfait !
3, 2, 1, GO !
Pffff...
[Bruit du public]
Yes!
♪ Dans le port d'Amsterdam...
♪ Y'a des marins qui chantent...
♪ Les rêves qui les hantent...
♪ Au large d'Amsterdam...
♪ Dans le port d'Amster...
Euh...
Le compte est bon !
2x8, 16
+4, 13
13x16, 208
divisé par 4, 52
52x7, 364 !
Oh!
Oh bonjour mon p'tit Romuald
Ah ben ça me fait plaisir de vous voir
[Bruit de vieux]
Ils m'entraînent ....
... au bout...
... de...
Aaaah...
Allez !
... la nuit.
Les démons de minuit ?
Ah!
Yes !
TOP!
Je suis une figure emblématique de la Révolution Française
Stéphanie, on a eu des supers bons moments....
Euh.... Corinne, on a les mêmes goûts musicaux, c'est fou...
Hélène, j'adore ta personnalité...
Mais euh... je vais choisir Sonia !
... et d'user de tous les expédients...
Je suis ? Je suis ? JE SUIS ?
Robespierre !
Eh non, c'est Danton.
Merci d'avoir participé Romuald.
Nous on se retrouve demain pour un nouveau
N'oubliez pas d'épouser le juste INTER Fort de la Fortune faible pour un Champion Factor
Aaaaargh !
[BIIIIIIIIP]
Mesdames et Messieurs les jurés
Dans notre société défigurée par l'omniprésence
de la culture télévisuelle
L'acte de mon client ne vous paraît-il pas...
... excusable ?
Nierez-vous le fait
que nos coutumes
nos moeurs
nos vies
sont parasités par la télévision ?
Nan ! Pas convaincu
Pour moi, ça va en prison
Pareil ! Mhmh !
[BUZZ]
On peut, en y souscrivant
être prévenu
de toutes les nouvelles...
Ouais bon, abonne-toi
Et tous les vendredis à 18h
Y'a aussi les vidéos du LAB
En exclusivité sur le site !...
... internet.